Today We're Going to Explore new Worlds
The Worlds inside The Vr. Anything Can Happen you've Seen that video Where the Guy Is trying to Kiss the anime girl
That Could be us, oh my God
it's Time for me to press end This moral Fresh Flesh and Become
Is that A car. Is that A Cop car. That's me
What is Happening hello?
How are you
Bring, oh Please, don't hurt me
How's your babe man of your day, I'm just Gonna go
I'm just gonna go away from you thank you
Shut Up Police isn't Pupusas
What are you gonna do fight me?
You want to go then this Bro?
You Know, What Wait Where do you go you Can, Teleport I'm gang dude your Chicken out
Pretty Good
I'm sorry
Are you I knew it get out of There will be no Top of the Morning to you
Really weird it sounds right away, okay, okay I
I move to Buy to the same week you fucking, did, oh how good does mine You Copied
Me it's i mean you can't beat Jack
don't you my brother that's Cold man a plus Makes me
Give you
do it I
Just Realized
it's me
Oh my god this is mental, oh my god are you making the video Please, don't tell me Y'all Make
Don't worry your sake Does Anyone want to Play Minecraft
Anyone want to Play Minecraft
Jesus Christ
Anybody Plays Overwatch Here Maybe yeah
Racism
Thank you so much
The Horse Please not fuck me
When you can't sure that's how We trained you oh, no I went away?
Jesus Christ Let It Take Long for Them to Recognize me what the hell
No, no, no no they Leprechaun I'm not a leprechaun I
Rip out your Lungs okay that's offensive okay, Please Apologize that's a microaggression
Please Listen I'm not A lie
Guys Cuz it I am
Jacksepticeye Top of the Morning to you laddies
I love Potatoes Please Spare me
Okay, I hate Potatoes Because I am not a leprechaun Wait how Does he Work
Totally Dangerous Potatoes
Weather Lady indeed I'll be on my merry way I
am
Jacksepticeye Top of the Morning to ya hey what is that guy's, oh?
my God it's rick for rick and morty I
Love Rick Good Morning, oh God
Alright Let's Just get out of Here and While no one Notices Just crawl out
Just crawl out no one will notice who wants some free Gold and Potato
your Big Quiet how dare you
You See the weight y to you thank you sir?
You want a new Avatar go Through that Portal Without Portal
I just want to see what
Rolling Me Right I'm not Dude man I'm not going
This Guy Better not Pick Trolling me
okay, There's more Advertiser
Oboe what the heck I'm gonna Pick This one This Is as close To an Anime babe
Didn't Work
Then They Work I
Think you're Worthless is it dude I'm Gonna Try it out I'm going Back hey Where do you find that I matter
I want to Look like an Anime Schoolgirl as, well now Keep that I need Help I need your help, ah
What Is this Fuzzy Looking Thing Get her away, from me back up, no i said back up what does he do it get Shush
Shush no, Shush I said Shush with you
Oh my god what are the giant Lady go, oh my God
oh
You want to challenge me You want to challenge me, oh you want to tell me?
You want to do it your finger out of my face you want to do it huh but you think Square, oh yeah
Square Up jax Quick I
Mean The Side the Side I'm right Here
oh
I have scooby snacks everyday
OHH NOOOOOOOOOOO!!!
*le iconic laugh*
This is so dumb They game on the Katana Monsters Digimon you're a Champion